[Música]
em 2013
eu tive uma experiência que mudou
completamente a trajetória da minha vida
eu fui pra nairobi no quênia fila pra
dar aula e também para construir uma
escola e quando cheguei lá e me deparei
com uma realidade que na minha opinião
nenhum ser humano devia viver na vida
eles não tinham quase nada de saneamento
básico pra vocês terem idéia e faziam as
necessidades em sacos plásticos a maior
parte da população jogava pela janela
não tinham acesso regular à rede
elétrica a educação era extremamente
precária não tinha acesso regular à água
potável
pra mim isso é uma coisa que ninguém
devia ter diferencial e uma das
principais dificuldades que a gente
tinha no ato de dar aula é porque a sala
de aula eram completamente escuras
para vocês terem uma noção de tudo que a
gente passava por lá a expectativa de
vida desta comunidade era de 30 anos de
idade
chamava mandarim seja estaria vivendo
agora o meu último ano de vida e dando
aula a gente ainda tinha esse desafio
será uma foto tirada dentro de uma sala
de aula os alunos não conseguir enxergar
nem o próprio caderno que a gente chama
tecnologia é muito simples para resolver
esse problema que tinha sido criado por
um brasileiro chamado alfredo monza que
era basicamente colocar uma garrafa pet
no telhado o sol batia e nossa garrafa
pet se espalhavam por dentro da sala
lembro bem que a gente fez a nossa
primeira instalação e essa é uma foto
dela que mostra o antes e depois era
sala ampla e está tampado com baldes e
sala depois e quando a gente viu a
diferença que simplesmente uma garrafa
pet por já fazer iluminando aquela sala
de aula
só que a gente não tá aí um projeto pra
gente fazer durante todo o nosso tempo
de intercâmbio e foi durante esse tempo
de intercâmbio que aconteceu algo muito
forte na minha vida que foi quando pela
primeira vez eu senti que pelo motivo
que eu acordava o meu trabalho o meu dia
a dia não era uma coisa esporádica só no
natal só na época do ano não mas meu
trabalho
o meu labor estava gerando algo para o
mundo estava tentando equilibrar um
pouco essa balança está tão
desequilibrada e pra mim manter esse
sentimento vivo era uma coisa muito
essencial na volta para o brasil porque
muitas vezes a gente acha que a à
pobreza só tá lá se instalar no quem não
vai para a áfrica é um erro brasil você
vai prazo esse vai pro pobreza e eu falo
para vocês hoje com quem já trabalha com
isso há cinco anos que o desafio que
qualquer pessoa que pegue um carro em 15
minutos de um centro urbano
você encontra uma favela uma comunidade
em situações muito parecidas com essa
que encontrei quando estava no quênia
então quando eu voltei pro brasil pensei
tá o que eu vou fazer para manter
sentimento vivido dentro de mim e aí eu
descobri que ainda tinha 2,7 milhões de
brasileiros sem acesso à energia
elétrica e que esse mesmo projeto
fazendo quem também poderia ser um ótimo
projeto para fazer no brasil a gente tem
com mais dois amigos a gente fundação
chamada lista de luís brasil já existe
essa marca nas filipinas silva lira fla
e agente fundo ela aqui no brasil e
basicamente começou a fazer a mesma
coisa a gente olhava comunidades que não
têm acesso à rede elétrica
vamos colocar uma garrafa no telhado das
casas
só que aí já vem um problema que é muito
comum um erro muito comum de pessoas que
vão trabalhar na área social que vem de
um lugar de privilégio que nem eu venho
que é ter uma prepotência muito comum a
gente achar que a gente sabe a solução
para o problema do outro então primeira
simples já tinha uma solução pronta que
essa garrafa já sabia como colocar em
telhados e eu vi que tinha população que
não tinha acesso regular à energia
elétrica falava logo vocês vão querer
uma garrafa sendo que na verdade é dona
maria então essa foto que a organização
provavelmente ela ficou assim tá vou
deixar esses meninos entrarem aqui
porque está insistindo muito tempo
dizendo que vai vai ser bom pra mim mas
no final a gente sinceramente ela deve
ter olhado e faço em meu deus nem subir
no meu telhado fizeram um buraco com uma
serra copo uma furadeira sujar minha
casa inteira pra botar uma garrafa que
na verdade
na minha opinião nem faz tanta diferença
assim nem time nem tanto porque já tenho
uma certa iluminação natural dentro de
casa ea
noite como ela não funciona e também
durante o dia quando estiver escuro
porque está frio alguma coisa assim
fechar a janela a maior parte das casas
em área urbana no brasil têm um gato
pelo menos de luiz elas têm
e essa é a realidade que a gente vive e
o que a gente deveria está fazendo na
verdade era ficar em silêncio e ouvir a
comunidade e entender qual é a sua
demanda qual é o seu problema em relação
à iluminação e aí sim tentar achar uma
solução que responda diretamente esse
problema
e foi isso que a gente começou a fazer
depois de um ano dando muito errado a
verdade é essa
e quando a gente começou a fazer isso a
gente viu que a necessidade era de
iluminação públicas usavam iluminação
pública nas ruas porque era muito
inseguro na noite em várias comunidades
urbanas e também comunidades isoladas e
na época morava em brasília eu fui na
unb conhecer a etec que a empresa júnior
de engenharia elétrica da unb eo lance
esse desafio
vamos criar uma solução que possa
iluminar essas comunidades à noite
porque hoje a única coisa que a gente
tem uma garrafa pet e foi que depois de
dois meses
a gente cria a nossa primeira tecnologia
e depois de seis meses a gente fez a
primeira instalação a essa é uma foto em
vila beira mar uma favela no rio de
janeiro que basicamente hoje a gente
utiliza placas solares baterias e
lâmpadas leds para iluminação noturna
não só pra áreas urbanas do brasil mas
principalmente para regiões isoladas
como comunidades ribeirinhas e quilombos
e só foi a partir do momento que a gente
resolveu se silenciar que o litro de
leite começou a expandir muito pelo
brasil ea gente começou a ser
reconhecido esse é um dos principais
prémios a nível global do meio ambiente
uma sã entre os pais podem variar entre
uma premiação na escócia de 100 mil
dólares que foi o que permitiu que a
gente realmente começar se os nossos
trabalhos na amazônia
além disso a gente hoje já engajou mais
de 200 voluntários pelo brasil fixo 200
voluntários que trabalham no limite de
luz
a gente tem funcionários contratados já
impacta a vida diretamente de mais de 10
mil pessoas
e aí eu gostaria de mostrar um pouquinho
pra vocês um vídeo pra vocês entenderem
melhor o qual que essa trajetória desde
o início e o que a gente tem feito hoje
em algumas unidades pelo brasil
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
ah ah ah ah ah ah
[Música]
e toda essa história gente que eu contei
pra vocês
ela falou que abriram as várias
oportunidades na minha vida como por
exemplo trabalhar e conhecer
pessoalmente o menino que pra mim é um
ser humano imagine o impacto social vivo
hoje na terra
foi uma grande honra na minha vida e
várias outras coisas representar o
letras de luz no equador num evento da
onu
mas uma coisa também que eu percebi
durante toda essa trajetória trabalho na
área social é que essas oportunidades
que eu tive principalmente essa vontade
está falando aqui com vocês hoje é algo
muito especial pra mim não é todo mundo
que tem essas oportunidades e quem me
lembrou muito a todo mundo que consegue
está aqui nesse lugar e não por mérito
mas porque muitas vezes nunca teve a
chance porque não teve o privilégio de
estar aqui e quem me lembrou disso muito
bem família chamada juliana teve um
vídeo impede que eu fiz um gol contra um
pouquinho da história do nascimento do
livro de luís e ela fez esse comentário
nesse ted ela diz assim cada vez que o
vejo ted ou aprofundar minha certeza que
o que domina seus sonhos no brasil é
você ter ou não dinheiro porque as
pessoas conseguem largar o emprego do
nada e viver o sonho em outro país para
dar aula de inglês tem que no mínimo ter
tido dinheiro pra fazer inglês quando
era mais novo
nasci na favela e me fala como vai
prosseguir um sonho desse forte essa
fala né
quando eu olhei me marcou bastante
isso começou a doer um pouco em mim
porque eu sinto que tem uma angústia é
uma dor na fala da juliana ea verdade é
que ela está certa porque eu fiz em
inglês durante a minha infância eu fiz
bons colégios particulares o que me
levaram a fazer universidades públicas
nas universidades
a porta se abriu e se eu conseguir bons
empregos nesse bom emprego eu consegui
ter o privilégio de juntar dinheiro para
fazer essa viagem por quênia quando eu
volto para o brasil e eu decido
empreender na área social que é um super
desafio
eu tive o apoio dos meus pais
porque eu venho de uma situação de
privilégio de meus pais podem sustentar
então o motivo de estar nestes tapete
vermelho aqui hoje muito é por causa dos
privilégios mas ao mesmo tempo senti uma
certa às vezes até um peso sabe um fardo
de está carregando privilégios isso pra
mim é um pouco estranho eu comecei a
pesquisar mais sobre esse assunto em dia
me deparei com essa imagem que pra mim é
muito simbólica né
ela diz assim a regra simples vem se
torna melhor que ele cruzar a linha de
chegada primeiro e é forte para mim
porque pra mim o conceito de sucesso
hoje está muito entre aquela linha de
chegada na linha de chegada a gente vê a
personagem de chegada e dizer aquela
pessoa bem sucedida sem olhar qual foi o
caminho que ela teve que percorrer para
a ale e pra mim eu fiquei pensando cá eu
me identifique demanda de várias
maneiras que esse cara porque eu sou
branco sou homem eu sou hétero
então dentro de todos os réus de
privilégios o acúmulo o acúmulo vários
deles mas também eu comecei a ver que
esse cara ele tem um caminho muito mais
livre para fazer chegar em situações de
poder porque para ela chegar numa
situação de poder onde ela possa mudar a
própria realidade é muito mais difícil
então também qual que é a minha
responsabilidade e foi me questionei a
partir do momento que eu entendo que o
meu caminho mais fácil para chegar nessa
linha de poder nessa linha de chegada
talvez para voltar aqui vamos porque se
a menina fosse juliana voltará que
destruíram esses obstáculos para tornar
a vida dela um pouco mais fácil ou prova
cabe quais são os obstáculos para que
próximas gerações não possam fazer isso
não precisa passar por essa mesma
promessa mesma vida ou mais ainda como
eu consigo das ferramentas pra ela pra
que ela conseguir facilmente esses
obstáculos e foi isso que eu comecei a
refletir muito durante a minha
trajetória e porque na verdade a gente
na essência
se vocês forem pesquisar a essência do
ser humano nós somos todos iguais
o potencial que a gente tem o mesmo tem
um conceito que eu amo que pra mim é o
melhor conceito de pobreza que existe
que por coincidência vendeu remedy anos
além disso que pessoas pobres são
pessoas bonsai que ele quer dizer com
isso disse que uma uma semente que você
planta numa floresta onde atua em todo
espaço para crescer e os nutrientes
chegar a uma área de 10 20 30 50 metros
de altura
mas é essa mesma semente você planta ela
num pote
ela vai crescer em 20 minutos ela vai
quase 30 ela vai parecer que nem aquela
árvore grande mas aqui nesse tamanho
porque ela não teve espaço suficiente
para crescer ea pobreza é isso a gente
nunca deu espaço à sociedade nunca deu
espaço para que essas pessoas pudessem
florescer no seu máximo potencial
elas nunca tiveram esse nutriente isso
dói prá mim porque isso me lembra muito
do meu tempo quando estava na áfrica não
estava no quênia
será mesmo que eu posso chegar para as
meninas da minha escola que estavam lá
com a mônica por exemplo e falasse
mônica fica tranquila que é só você se
esforçar muito que você vai alcançar o
que alcancei
é só você se esforçar muito quando a
expectativa de vida dela é de 30 anos de
idade quando a alimentação dela na
primeira infância na primeira infância
foi terrível só à base de carboidrato
isso já e já comprometeu completamente
desenvolvimento cognitivo da pressa da
vida e só aí você já está perpetuando a
pobreza muitas vezes isso muda a
estrutura física de uma pessoa
alimentação que ela teve
será mesmo que esse conceito de
meritocracia pode ser colocado numa
situação como essa e para mim é um
exemplo muito clássico disse que eu
gosto de dar é desse bebê que está nessa
foto recebendo essa foto é filho de um
queniano e ele poderia ser como qualquer
outra daquelas crianças que tavam na
minha escola na escola que eu dava aula
vivem a mesma realidade com expectativa
de vida daquelas mas ele foi criado por
uma mãe que cuidava muito na educação
dele e ele foi criado num ambiente numa
terra muito fértil onde ele poderia
estudar onde ele teve acesso
a tutoria e basicamente essa semente
floresceu ao ponto de se tornar um dos
homens mais poderosos do mundo e na
essência quando eu olho para essa
criança eu sei que ela teve o mesmo
potencial que todas aquelas outras
crianças que eu gostei pra vocês e pra
mim o grande presente de você entender a
sua situação de privilégio porque nem
toda semente
gente que você planta não até a festa
ela vai florescer nem toda semente não é
isso que eu quero dizer
mas a beleza de você entender o seu
privilégio entender que o seu privilégio
é uma oportunidade para que você possa
alcançar o seu potencial porque tem
muita gente que por mais forçadas que
seja nunca foi colocado nessa situação
de poder mesmo com todo o seu esforço
florescer em toda a sua potência e aí me
dói muito quando vejo amigos por exemplo
que estão a seguir carreiras totalmente
desconectada de si mesmo quando eles têm
todos os privilégios do mundo pra mudar
de faculdade por que um pai pode arcar
com isso
ou pode resolver se aventurar e fazer
uma viagem ou mudar de emprego porque
ele tem uma família que tem uma
estrutura pode permitir quantas pessoas
aqui simplesmente não podem escolher o
trabalho que elas têm por que ela tem
que acordar não pois nem escolheu
estudar
imagina poder escolher o trabalho que
tem por que tem que acordar às 4 horas
da manhã pra chegar no trabalho porque
tem que ajudar dentro de casa quando
jovens são já os pais que vão ajudar os
avós e pra mim entender que cada um aqui
tem sua situação de privilégio e sabe
qualquer cada um tem sua única situação
de privilégio para mim uma das pessoas
que mais me inspira na minha vida eu
tenho muita gratidão por ela é o seu
nelson que é esse da foto e hoje é
aniversário dele por coincidência seu
nelson ele é nosso voluntário - novo
como eu gostaria de dizer em letra de
lei se está fazendo é de 68 anos quando
a gente está voltando à nossa primeira
ação da amazônia que essa foto que vocês
estão vendo eu brinco que são japonês 66
anos consegue fazer isso né
a gente estava no fundo desse barco
voltando à nossa primeira ação no
momento muito bonito onde todo mundo
estava manifestando que tinha sentido
como tinha sido a sua experiência para
cada um tinha sido a nossa primeira
grande aventura no livro de luís estava
todo mundo compartilhem no final seu
nelson veio trazer a mensagem dele e
quando ele veio trazer a mensagem dele
ele já começou chorando e as copas já
todo mundo começou a chorar e ele
manifestou assim ele falou
gente eu trabalhei mais de 30 anos na
mesma empresa
e foi aqui no livro de luís com 66 anos
de idade se pela primeira vez encontrei
meu lugar no mundo
eu queria agradecer muito vocês por isso
eu agradeço muito a ele por isso porque
ele que ele que possibilitou isso
e pra mim aí tá beleza também da gente
lutar contra essa cultura tão é que
pressiona a gente encontrar o nosso
propósito ontem uma criança 18 anos até
encontrar o propósito dela com 20 anos
profissionais é uma grande inspiração
que mostra pra gente que os nossos
privilégios a nossa vida vai bater na
porta várias vezes trazendo
oportunidades para que a gente possa
encontrar nosso lugar do mundo
eu espero muito aqui que todo mundo
possa encontrar o seu
obrigado gente
[Música]